Apple's M3 Max including the
long-awaited M3 MacBook Air are just
around the corner and in this video I
have five new very important updates to
share with you guys that you need to
know especially if you decide to hold
off on a Mac purchase right now so
getting right into update number one
this one comes from Mark German who is
by far the most reliable Apple leaker
out there and he just posted a fresh
version of his power on newsletter with
a huge update of what to expect this
fall his sources have just let him know
about a special October event where
Apple will be launching some new
products and based on past history Mark
believes it's most likely to be some new
Max and better yet he even gave us the
exact models he expects to get updated
with the M3 chip first the 13-inch
MacBook Air the 24 inch iMac and the
13-inch MacBook Pro now if you're
holding out for the high-end M3 Pro and
M3 Max MacBook Pros don't hold your
breath because he says it's way too
early for those and they're likely not
coming until at least the end of next
year but getting back to the new M3 Max
expected to launch first I'm honestly
surprised that they mentioned the
13-inch MacBook Pro because I expected
it to be cut from the lineup by now or
at least redesigned but who knows and as
for the iMac I honestly think it'll come
around six months after the 13-inch
MacBook Air since that's exactly what
happened with the M1 model launch the M1
Air Pro and Mac Mini came in the fall of
2020 and the M1 iMac only came in the
spring of 2021 so expect the same thing
to happen this time around if the M3
launches this fall now moving on to
update number two we have some updates
on the performance numbers and it's
honestly not looking as good as we
previously thought for some context I
made a video where I estimated the
performance of the M3 chip using some
math previous calculations and a17
bionic performance leaks which were
incredibly impressive and as you can see
the single core performance came out to
around 3 500 points in geekbench 6 which
is around 32 faster than the M2 Chip
which is insane and then for the
multi-core test we're looking at around
600 points in geekbench 6 which is
around 41.5 faster than the M2 now all
of that sounds great but after I made
that video we had some unexpected and
fairly disappointing news Tech Reeve on
Twitter who is the same Source who
leaked the initial a17 bionic chip
performance numbers said that the new
a17 and M3 chips could actually have
disappointing performance compared to
what he saw before apparently instead of
them being based on a brand new
architecture there could just be
Improvement events to the manufacturing
process to get them to three nanometer
so don't expect the performance numbers
I estimated to be that high
realistically we could be looking at
about 20 percent higher for single core
and maybe 25 to 30 percent higher for
multi-core just to temper the
expectations a little bit and if it
turns out to be even better that'll be a
welcome surprise now for update number
three I know that we just got the
15-inch MacBook Air and it's been
amazing but we already have some info on
the new M3 chip packed 15-inch air
according to German Apple has already
started work on that large 15-inch M3
MacBook Air which makes sense but what's
unclear is that this report was from
June and it mentioned both the 13 inch
and 15 inch models at the same time
however in his most recent power on
newsletter when he mentioned an October
event where we could see the first M3
Max he gave a list of three Mac models
and the 15-inch wasn't included at all
just a 13 inch air the 24 inch iMac and
the 13-inch MacBook Pro now in my
opinion if the 13 inch M3 air is really
coming this October it's first of all
way too soon for a 15 inch update
alongside the smaller model but also I
think it actually makes sense to delay
the 15-inch M3 MacBook Air Model just
like they did for the brand new 15 inch
that we have now which was released
basically a full year after the 13 inch
M2 MacBook Air and why do I think that
well because I think Apple wants to give
users a choice when they first M3 chip
Max finally come you can either choose
the 15 inch air with the old M2 Chip or
you can get the brand new M3 but only in
the 13 inch size so there's a bit of a
dilemma that makes sure people still
have a reason to go for that 15 inch air
for the size to Value ratio and then a
few months later Apple can come out with
the new 15-inch M3 air and get another
big boost in sales basically just how
Apple adds a new iPhone color in the
spring or like when they release the
iPhone SE in the spring for a sales
boost taking advantage of people's tax
refunds however what if the M3 Max get
delayed and don't actually launch until
next year well in that case I think
Apple could release both the 13 and
15-inch MacBook Air models at the same
time and why would they get delayed well
that brings us to update number four if
you haven't already heard both the a17
and M3 chips will be built on tsmc's new
three nanometer chip process and
unfortunately really we've been getting
reports that the chip yields are lower
than expected which means there will be
less three nanometer chip Supply and
because of that people are starting to
get worried that there won't be enough
three nanometer chips left over for the
M3 until next year meaning a delayed
launch Tech Reeve on Twitter who was the
same guy who leaked those performance
benchmarks recently said that he was
worried that tsmc's N3 process will have
such low yields that it might be a
barrier to production of the a17 chip
but this seems to have been resolved by
postponing M3 to next year and
apparently the yields were so low that
they switched from the original M3
process to n3e which has better yields
but worse transistor density and
performance but it's okay because
according to this chart that he posted
the n3e transistor density is still
better then Samsung's brand new three
nanometer process and that's actually a
really smart move by Apple where right
now they're going to be a little bit
ahead of their competition giving them
even more room next time around for a
bigger performance jump with N3 but even
still we just got a report recently
showing that three nanometer yields at
tsmc for the a17 and M3 chips are
sitting at around 55 yield which is
terrible so we might get a delay until
the spring of 2024 and then adding even
more fuel to the delay fire we just got
a new leak from the information claiming
that the iPhone 15 Pro Models are
experiencing display production issues
due to having incredibly thin bezels but
they don't think that this will lead to
a delay however we just had another big
Source claim that the iPhone 15 is
actually getting delayed until October
and that's from the same analyst who was
right about the iPhone 12 delay years
ago and then if that happened it would
likely push the first M3 Mac launch back
even further if they were planned to be
launched in October especially if the
iPhone delays have anything to do with
bad chip yields on top of the display
issues but then flipping back again we
have update number five and this one was
actually quite interesting just the
other day we got a report from digit
times that Apple's new 13-inch MacBook
Pro with a three nanometer chip will be
launching in the third quarter of this
year now the third quarter thing doesn't
really make sense because we're
literally in the third quarter right now
and it ends before October pointing to a
September launch which doesn't really
make any sense but one important key
detail is that they say it'll have the
M3 chip based on three nanometer
technology apology which perfectly
matches the same information from Mark
German who hinted at an October launch
now personally I think that the 13-inch
MacBook Pro should just get discontinued
completely since it just doesn't make
sense in the lineup and it's really
outdated but in the eyes of Apple it's
probably incredibly profitable and
people are surprisingly still buying
these things probably due to the pro
title at a cheaper price but all in all
I'm leaning more towards these M3 Max
getting delayed until next year due to
all these three nanometer chip yield
issues and everything else but both Mark
German and digitimes think that the
yields are just fine and they're coming
this fall so I might end up being wrong
but anyway hopefully you enjoy this
video and these new updates on the M3
MacBook Air and if you enjoyed it click
that Circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one and check out one
of those two great videos right there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one
[Music]